this is a protest that's just now
started
outside new scotland yard on the
embankment in westminster
this protest a direct response to the
events on clapham common
last night i'm going to pop out the way
and just let
the camera get a flavor of the shots
here you can see
two or three hundred people here at
least near that iconic
new scotland yard sign of course well
known throughout the world
they're here to protest as i say
not just about the events of last night
but
of course to pay their respects to sarah
everard and to raise the uh
the public's awareness about the
violence against women in general that's
why they're here
now clearly just like last night because
of the numbers here
you can see they're all absolutely
packed in like sardines in this
small sort of concourse area just
outside scotland yard
they are in contravention of lockdown
rules
now police because of concerns in fact
just
you can see some more police
reinforcements arriving
outside new scotland yard now a lot of
women in the contingent there as well
because
a great deal of criticism about the fact
that
when police backup came in
reinforcements
there were women initially but male
police officers
to supplement the numbers because
there's only so many
women police officers that were
available at that time mail officers
were in there and they were
directly involved in arrests which of
course upset
uh a lot of people so as i was saying
the uh
the situation here at the moment is that
uh they are
clearly not complying with uh covert
rules and regulations but given
the furoria over what happened last
night in here
the arrests that followed a decision by
the police because they said
of real concerns over uh health
because of the way in which people were
crammed in together they moved in to try
and start dispersing people and that's
of course when hostilities
began a lot of fallout a lot of pressure
on the metropolitan police commissioner
cressida dick
i can tell you that she is currently
involved
in doing an interview for the television
cameras uh which we will bring to you
as soon as we can we're not exactly sure
what she is going to say her colleagues
her officers
uh last night were talking about
being left with no choice but to
intervene because of the fact that
people
were crammed in together in such a small
space and not just that there were they
say hostile elements
in the crowd that were shouting at the
police uh were pushing and then began
throwing
uh items at the police as well and that
necessitated them
to move in and start arresting people
there
that explanation though has not
satisfied the london mayor sadiq khan
he wants an independent investigation
not satisfied
with president dick's remarks and
explanation apparently
and further pressure of course a notable
intervention
from the home secretary who
said that she found some of the scenes
that she saw on social media
last night you know
she was very concerned and worried by
those scenes the
home office minister victoria atkins was
on
sophie ridge's programme this morning
again she didn't give a fulsome support
to the home secretary she said that we'd
have to wait to see
what crested dick said in response
to the events of last night now you can
see as we speak that
the police are putting up more barriers
to guard the area around new scotland
yard
keeping the protesters who are arriving
all of the time here
i don't know if you can see them over
there they're actually spilling out
onto the roadway onto the embankment
itself because there are
significant numbers of people who have
decided
to turn up in defiance of police
warnings not to because of the fact they
would be breaking the law
and in response to the scenes that they
saw with
a number of people four was the last
count given to us by the metropolitan
police
uh arrested as a result of
events down on clapham common so it's
peaceful at the moment but
uh there is certainly a tension in the
area
this event has been organized by
a group called sisters uncut now they
are not reclaim the streets
reclaim the streets say that they had
uh for days try to engage with scotland
yard
with a view to having a smaller scale
socially distanced vigil which they
believed would have satisfied health
requirements and
would not have led to the scenes last
night where many more than
were originally planned to turn out onto
clapham common
decided to turn out in defiance of that
police ban so
here again today is to say we're seeing
them here just outside new scotland yard
certainly so far of course a different
response
from the police but to be fair to the
police it was a different response
yesterday as well until events
did start to deteriorate a lot of female
officers that were
visible only later as the crowd
according to the metropolitan police
began to
become more hostile were other officers
and
by necessity just because of the numbers
of female officers on duty at that time
there were male officers in there as
well so
tense here people determined to have
their
voices heard though despite the fact
that they know they could be risking
arrest